ce sont des dizaines d'agents du
département 6 à faire chaque jour pour
réaliser les nombreux décors qui seront
installés dans le jardin de l'état à
l'occasion de la manifestation au
bonheur des enfants des mois de
préparation pour que durant une semaine
la magie de noël submerge les petits
réunionnais trois mois tout le personnel
c'est à dire le service des prix mieux
comprendre soixantaine de personnes
encadrantes confondues aider certaines
datent de l'année bien compte à rebours
exprimé les besoins du client
les caf de fata chaque week-end plus de
40 agents donnent de leur temps pour la
réalisation des décors dans la bonne
humeur et l'esprit les clips
j'aime ce que je fais et puis on
rencontrait un objectif et qu'on a je
vais jusqu'au bout donc
donc là c'est pour aussi la motiver tout
le monde
elle bat l'entente entre responsables et
agents
ben dis donc si nous a aussi motivé
tu n'es pas travailler comme chaque
année à la proche des fêtes de noël
petits et grands seront invités à un
voyage imaginaire autour d'un thème le
thème est venu sur le bonheur des
enfants 2015 puisque une fois qu'on a
réalisé celui de 2015 ou ce 10 mai de
l'année prochaine qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir encore faire et c'est vrai que
l'idée est venue très vite puisqu'on
savait que cette année 2016 on allait
vivre un moment extraordinaire le 1er
septembre avec l'éclipsé annulaire ou la
réunion était le point de vue le plus
intéressant à l'échelle internationale
pour pouvoir voir cette éclipse et c'est
à partir de là qu'on se dit pas pourquoi
pas cette année sur le thème du cosmos
des planètes beaucoup beaucoup
d'éléments qu'on a recyclé en termes de
structure mais aussi en terme de
décoration qu'on avait fabriqué qu'on a
pu ré exploiter en matériaux en fait qui
nous servent de support et ensuite on
vient habiller en fait c'est sûr il ya
énormément de recyclage
on s'en rend pas bien compte parce que
voilà tout a été transformée aujourd'hui
on ne se rappelle même plus à dans quel
état il était à vendre
féerique magique enchanteur de nombreux
adjectifs pour qualifier au bonheur des
enfants
libre à chacun de définir cette
manifestation comme il le souhaite
organisation esprit d'équipé
la fête pétards fusées ferry
solidaires et compétences voyage rêverie
et magie il y en aurait un quatrième
s'est bonne humeur la manifestation au
bonheur des enfants se déroulera au
jardin de l'état du 13 au 21 décembre